i think some conservatives are lulling
themselves into complacency
because they believe that joe biden
is a kind of moderate guy he's not bill
de blasio he's not
elizabeth warren he's not bernie sanders
he's just a kind of moderate guy right
therefore it doesn't really matter if
trump wins
joe biden is not awake joe biden
doesn't remember his name sometimes joe
biden's campaign is being run
by radicals don't take my word for it
campaign just issued its spending plan
you know how expensive the joe biden
campaign spending plan is
the moderate campaign spending plan
10 trillion dollars 10
trillion with a t 2 trillion dollars
to fight climate change so 20
2 trillion of that price tag is going to
be spent
launching a battle against the sun
monster 1.3 trillion for infrastructure
i can actually get behind infrastructure
in theory
except that usually that money is just
completely wasted
you know you're driving on the highway
and you see 15 guys standing around
doing nothing and then one guy may be
swinging a hammer and you say that's
there's a government union job there it
is
so in theory it's maybe it's okay but in
practice probably not
750 billion dollars for health care i
thought i thought barack obama and joe
biden
solved the health care problem what was
it now 10 years ago
11 years ago remember joe biden himself
said this is a big effing deal
how can we need to spend three quarters
of a trillion dollars on health care if
you already solved it 10 11 years ago
because there's no end to it there's no
solving it there's no solving it with
it's just gonna be more and more and
more money 750 billion dollars for
higher education
that's what we need we need to uh send
three quarters of a trillion dollars to
our modern-day madrasas
the madrassas of liberalism to to borrow
a phrase
from my friend josh hammer who these
schools
all they do is indoctrinate people in
leftist ideology
a lot of money for that 700 billion for
biden's buy american plan which
apparently he stole from bernie sanders
640 billion for housing 125 billion
dollars for biden's opioid plan
what is the biden's uh what is the
opioid plan this
last time i could tell all the left is
trying to do is legalize more and more
drugs maybe
maybe 125 billion to legalize them 30
billion for criminal justice reform
means springing
springing inmates out of prisons
although frankly republicans aren't any
better on that
and 750 billion dollars for preschool in
k-12 which is
where most of the educational battles
are really fought it happens
that the indoctrination happens long
before college so three-quarters of a
trillion for that
and then more than three-quarters of a
trillion for universal preschool
expanded child care
you know get those kids out of the home
as soon as possible
get them into state-sponsored education
camps
10 trillion on all sorts of bad stuff
those are the stakes don't let anybody
tell you that joe biden
is going to be the moderate guy that's
not moderate the moderation is gone
joe biden is a guy who doesn't want to
do anything as president he wants to be
president he wants
bridges to be named after him and
highways to be named after him
he's going to let all the policy making
be done by the younger people who are
much much
more radical i hope you enjoyed that
short segment from the michael knowles
show be sure to check out the full
episode linked in the description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts